et d'amener la police à prendre en compte
la possibilité d'une mort récente quand on découvre des ossements.
Revenons sur l'importance de l'enquête sur l'enlèvement.
J'ai expliqué aux inspecteurs
que les vautours aiment les lieux où il y a de l'eau,
où il y a des cerfs de Virginie.
Ils arrivent souvent dans les cinq jours suivant la mort.
Ils laissent la colonne vertébrale intacte, et des plumes.
Les inspecteurs m'ont répondu :
« Nous avons trouvé le corps dans une fosse peu profonde.
Nous avons aussi trouvé les plumes que vous avez évoquées. »
Mais il semblait y avoir un problème
car on avait retrouvé les plumes à 35 mètres du corps,
à côté d'une pomme de pin couverte de sang.
Les vautours ne sont pas attirés par le sang et ils ne se promènent pas.
Ils peuvent s'éloigner d'une dizaine de mètres mais pas 35.
Ça serait une perte d'énergie
pour un oiseau qui ne sait pas quand sera son prochain repas.
Ma première tâche fut donc de vérifier la présence de vautours sur la scène.
Les plumes près de la pomme de pin appartenaient bien à un urubu.
Mais pourquoi diable un vautour s'éloignerait-il de 35 mètres ?
J'adore les vautours notamment parce qu'ils fonctionnent
selon des principes biologiques et physiques.
J'ai donc passé en revue les expériences que j'avais menées pour les appâter
dans une ferme des morts au Texas,
un de ces endroits où l'on peut faire don de son corps à la science.
J'ai aussi revisité mes expériences avec le piégeage
et le marquage GPS des vautours,
suivie par une année de surveillance des vautours,
grâce à la localisation par GPS.
Ensuite, j'ai relu mes notes et j'ai eu une inspiration.
Deux choses pouvaient attirer un vautour à 35 mètres d'un corps.
Les entrailles et la matière cérébrale.
J'ai présenté cette information aux inspecteurs
et j'ai appris qu'ils soupçonnaient que la victime avait été immobilisée
par un coup violent au crâne.
Le coup à la tête aurait été administré là où on avait trouvé la pomme de pin,
et la victime aurait ensuite été traînée sur 35 mètres
pour être enterrée dans une fosse peu profonde.
Ce qui suggère que c'est la matière cérébrale qui a appâté le vautour.
Ça illustre comment l'étude du comportement des vautours
peut aider à reconstituer une partie des faits.
Les inspecteurs m'ont aussi envoyé cette photo.
Le bras de la victime dépasse de la fosse.
En tant que scientifique légiste, vous devez tout prendre en considération.
La plume près de la pomme de pin indiquait la présence de vautours sur les lieux.
Cette photo de la scène du crime dévoile
des indices d'un comportement caractéristique des charognards.
En zoomant sur la photo, on voit une plume de duvet blanc,
caractéristique de l'urubu à tête rouge.
Vous remarquerez aussi que la peau
montre une déchirure semblable à une entaille près du poignet.
L'urubu à tête rouge sent la décomposition et atterrit.
Il passe à travers les aiguilles de pin,
extrait la main,
déchire la peau avec son bec,
puis commence à arracher les tissus mous de l'os.
Il déchire et arrache, déchire et arrache, déchire et arrache.
Cette photo illustre l'efficacité des vautours.
Cela est important parce que ça corrobore la chronologie
élaborée par les enquêteurs pour ce meurtre.
Il n'y a pas beaucoup d'indices.
Vous n'allez sûrement pas voir les vautours sur la scène du crime.
Mais les vautours laissent des indices très subtils.
Plutôt que de chercher le vautour,
cherchez des plumes et des os immaculés.
Les vautours sont importants parce qu'ils sont si doués et si rapides.
Ils sont comme des tornades.
Un clignement des yeux et ils sont partis.
J'ai donné mon avis sur ces preuves à l'inspecteur.
Et il a présenté les preuves apportées par les vautours au tribunal.
Cette affaire d'enlèvement était un cas de peine de mort.
L'accusé a été déclaré coupable.
Cette affaire démontre comment l'étude du comportement des vautours
aide à innover en médecine légale.
La victime d'un assassinat mérite une enquête des plus méticuleuses.
Lorsque nous tenons compte des vautours,
nous brossons un tableau plus détaillé des événements, de quand ça s'est passé
et des victimes.
La prochaine fois que vous vous retrouvez sur les lieux d'un crime avec un cadavre —
(Rires)
regardez au sol pour trouver les indices abandonnés par les vautours.
Et si jamais quelqu'un vous parle de vautours à un rendez-vous,
vous saurez que vous tenez la bonne personne.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)